what is up everybody its Anna Mac for
anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the darkest demon
transformation in the seven deadly sins
a transformation that can turn a higher
ranked demon into a ruthless and
tireless machine of destruction the name
of the form achieved with this
transformation is in Duda and we have
seen several in Duda beasts throughout
the course of the seven deadly sins
story in this video I will explain
everything that we know about the Enduro
transformation and all the known in Duda
beasts that we have seen so far in the
story including the ndu reforms of Mon
speed and derriere II Before we jump
into it I want to give a quick thank you
to black desert for sponsoring this
video
black desert is an online MMORPG that
I've been playing for almost a year and
for me this is a game that truly stands
out from the competition you can build
your own custom character from scratch
there are 18 diverse classes to choose
from and the character creation system
is incredibly detailed black desert
features real-time action based combat
which includes fast paced combos and
diverse weapons and fighting styles that
make for an epic gaming experience the
graphics are beautiful and the vast
fantasy setting is amazing don't take my
word for it you have to see it for
yourself the game is constantly being
updated and the latest update called the
great expedition has just been launched
only a few weeks ago the great
expedition features a new ocean trading
system a new ocean boss new high class
ships and so much more try it out for
yourself just click the link in the
description for a free 7-day trial and
you will see exactly why this game is so
much fun to play heads up there will be
some spoilers in this video about the
true nature of the Endura transformation
as well as the unique powers and
abilities of the Endura beasts that we
have seen so far in the series this will
include information from the manga and
the seven deadly sins prisoners of the
sky movie but I want to make it clear
that I will only be talking about the
form itself and the powers of the
different Endora beasts that we have
seen so
far I will not be spoiling the plot
itself and what ultimately happens to
the Endora in the story the first Endora
transformation that we see takes place
during the previous holy war when man
speed and ariari were fighting against
three of the four Archangels from the
goddess clan Tarmey else Arielle and Lou
Rochelle were clearly overpowering their
yerim on speed and their demon allies
and their Aryan man speed determined
that the only way they could stand a
chance against the Archangels as if they
transformed into Endora beasts so what
is the Endora transformation and how
does it work
a demon who wants to turn into an
enduring must make a pact with darkness
and sacrifice six of their seven demon
hearts in order to initiate the
transformation only a high-ranked demon
with a power level of over 50,000 before
the transformation is capable of
becoming Endora
if a demon with a lower power level
attempts the same ritual their body will
not be able to take the transformation
and they will simply die the powerful
demons who do survive the transformation
will gain an incredible power boost but
at a price their bodies will transform
into monstrous animalistic entities and
they will lose all sense of reason and
rationality the Endora is a completely
wild beast whose only instinct is to
destroy everything around them they're
basically incredibly powerful giant
berserkers more akin to a deadly force
of nature than to the rational
individuals that they used to be before
the transformation the indirect
transformation is normally permanent so
once a demon makes the decision to make
that sacrifice they will remain that way
and in fact numerous Endora beasts are
still set to roam the demon realm to
this day the demon realm is of course
the realm from which the demons
originate and it is said that even the
regular demons within the demon realm
fear the wrath of the rampaging Endora
beasts this transformation is set to
bring out each demons true nature the
most vicious and bloodthirsty aspect of
who they are
each Indra is unique in appearance and
there are various types of Endora which
bear different names
and titles in the movie prisoners of the
sky we meet a beast called the Endora of
retribution whereas those beasts who
were created through the sacrifice of
one of the ten commandments are referred
to as the Indra of favor
in fact the Endora of favor are said to
be far stronger than the other varieties
of Endora and because they were members
of the Ten Commandment at the time both
derriere II and man speed became this
type of beast the Endora of favor once
their Aryan man's Pete do transform they
easily overpower three of the four
Archangels including sorry alt Armijo
and Ludo shell even though they were
losing the fight before they transformed
by becoming Endora dairy Aryan man speed
completely turned the tide of the battle
which demonstrates just how amazing this
transformation is as dairy Aryan man
speed fight there Endora forms appear to
grow more and more monstrous they start
off fairly similar to their original
forms with some monstrous alterations
but then they continue to change and
become increasingly monstrous as the
fight progresses the Endora are believed
to be so powerful that the only way to
defeat them is to allow them to keep
rampaging and destroying everything in
sight until they run out of strength and
eventually die from exhaustion we have
never actually seen this happen so we
have no idea how long this process would
actually take years decades centuries
since we know that some in drive
apparently been roaming the demon realm
for a very long time the idea of just
waiting for them to exhaust themselves
in battle seems highly impractical but
something very interesting happens
during the battle between the Archangels
and their Aryan moms speed just as it
seems as though the massive battle is
going to destroy the entire fairy Kings
forest Elizabeth in her original goddess
body interferes she manages to use her
incredible goddess powers to purify
maaan speed and derriere II which
actually turns them back into their
normal demon forms and also knocks them
unconscious due to Elizabeth's very
specific goddess powers their Aryan man
speed were not condemned to spend the
rest of their lives as senseless beasts
of destruction and they were able to
return to their normal bodies with that
said we do meet a few other Endura
beasts who appear to have been in those
forms for a very long time one of them
is the previously mentioned Endora of
retribution which is one of the main
antagonists of the seven deadly sins
prisoners of the sky movie this Endora
used to be a demon called baraha and
before his transformation he was an
acquaintance of the demon Galland
at some point during the holy war baru
ha in his Endora form along with the six
nights of black and other demons were
sealed inside the egg rock by the great
oh [ __ ] oh this happened during a
massive battle at the sky temple in the
present time some 3,000 years later the
seal breaks and Beru ha along with the
other demons is released eventually
leading to an epic battle between Baloo
ha and the seven deadly sins
due to his massive physical size but who
has the power to rampage and destroy
virtually everything in sight and he is
also able to launch massive energy
blasts at his opponents another Endora
beast that we meet later on in the story
is the massive chimera Indra
that looks like a mishmash of various
animals and beasts put together into a
single grotesque monster this monster is
so huge that it makes even Giants look
small by comparison and we know that
this chimera Indra is also an enduro
favor which means that the demon who
became this creature must have been a
former member of the ten commandments we
do not know which former commandment
turned into this beast
it could become a Dios or it could be
some completely different former member
that we've never even heard of along
with the usual demonic powers this
Endora also has the special ability to
launch thousands of sentient spores from
its body these spores are able to go off
on their own and grow into monsters who
are capable of wrecking havoc across all
of Britannia if they were allowed to run
loose and there are likely several other
indoor beasts still roaming around
inside the demon realm but we haven't
been properly introduced to them as of
right now although we have seen some
faint glimpses throughout the manga what
we do know is that the Endora are
incredibly powerful and destructive
demons and in order to stand again
one of them it takes the seven deadly
sins all working together
anyway involving other allies like the
mother of chaos considering how strong
some of the sins are right now that is
saying a lot personally I find this
concept of the Endura transformation
very interesting especially the idea of
sacrificing one's reason for power and
then becoming a wild rampaging beast
interested in nothing but destruction it
actually kind of reminds me of the
Titans from attack on Titan especially
pure Titans sure if someone is turned
into a Titan they get a massive power
boost but they also become senseless
beasts who want nothing else but to
devour humans just like the Endura who
are senseless beasts who just want to
destroy this seems like a pretty
terrible existence for the actual person
involved the Endura
is said to be the true nature of the
demons but I don't think this is true
this transformation seems to bring out
and amplify all of the worst instincts
of a demon but we know that there are
many demons out there whose nature is
far more complex than just a desire to
destroy we know this from a Leora's cell
drous their Aryan man speed the original
goal thir and many others at the end of
the day the Endura is just an
exaggerated anime version of the
struggle that all of us face daily we
all have some dark instincts within us
the instinct to be greedy vengeful
spiteful aggressive and so on but most
of the time we are reasonable enough to
know that giving in to these instincts
would be harmful for us and for the
people around us the Endura form takes
away the ability to reason and resists
harmful instincts and it unleashes and
amplifies the worst traits of every
individual this is not their true nature
it's just the worst aspects of their
nature which is something that all of us
have to come to terms with including us
non demonic humans but let me know what
you guys think what are your thoughts on
the Endura transformation and do you
wish that we got to see even more of
these beasts in the story also do you
agree with me that their area is still
waifu even in her Endora form let me
know down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more 7le sense
content on this channel please leave a
like to let me know if it really does
help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications don't forget to
check out our sponsor black desert
online click the link in the description
for a 7-day free trial as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]